this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Kristen it's a pleasure to see
you all today I am going to talk about
some of my connection to work in the the
farm-to-table movement part of why it's
really special to me I grew up my family
has a farm not too far down the road
from Cornell and so working on that from
Cornell has a great special resonance
with me and thinking about kind of why
arm to table matters thinking about the
importance of food to us as we have
throughout humanity celebrated harvests
express our gratitude for food or mend
the meals that bring us together the
meals you'll have here at reunion will
be kind of your gathering points food
has been really a central event and
sharing food has been a central event
for our lives and as we have in the past
two generations one of the tendencies
we've seen is for people to be bit more
disconnected for that and one of the
movements we see is people being very
interested in reconnecting with where
their food comes from we see more young
young farmers getting engaged with
agriculture again we see other people
just wanting to be connected to the
process other people just looking to see
no more where is the food coming from
feel more connected to that experience
and so as we have started to have this
movement this reappraise or connecting
with food and how it's grown and can be
grown locally sourced locally and feel
more kind of connected to the process
it's something that helps build and
empower communities and new varieties
new cultivars to help that is one of the
areas I contribute if we extend beyond
that but it's one of the areas is the
most personal and special to me and in
that process look beyond just looking to
benefits to create new varieties for
a farm for a grower for the food system
a critical thing is the consumer from
the food system all of us and how can we
empower us to be navigating that with
the choices that we're wanting to make
trying to make taking about freshness
nutrition sustainability all the choices
we make how do we how do we find our way
through the fruits and with so many new
crops so many opportunities to give food
some advertising a produce how do we
know that we're making the choices we
think we're making and so my apologies
for anyone that has any memories of
taking multiple choice tests in this
room before in Calcutta durian but this
is the test the the choice you might
have in the market place is looking
between these two squash and which one
is the righteous which one is the most
nutritious one of them happens to be
ripe and ready for the market and the
other one is not ready so how do you
tell which one is the most delicious
most nutritious so how about if through
plant breeding we can change the
question and make it an easier question
so now a and B which one is the ripe
Asst so this is a honey nut squash one
of the products I've helped develop and
so clearly B is the ripe one it has a
rightness indicator so like a green
versus a yellow banana a green versus a
red tomato this rightness indicator it
empowers you to go through the grocery
store to find or the market to be able
to find the produce that's the ripe fost
that'd be the most delicious it is also
not only can you tell when it's right
that's naturally more nutrition has more
vitamin A a great antioxidant for your
health provide M&A so the honey o squash
all the way on your right B will have
three times the beta carotene content
this provitamin a activity as the
ripeness of the squash in your left in
ten
as much as you would find on the less
ripe one you see and so this gives you a
way to be to find some that's going to
be delicious when you bring it home to
your family when you grow it and along
with that you get the the flavor the
nutrition and not only is it something
that it's helping some farms to be able
to have an identifiable product where
they can kind of guarantee the quality
and you can understand that what you're
getting it also helps people change some
of their dietary choices because rather
than going through the produce and
finding some things maybe not to your
taste maybe you can get them at their
peak and maybe this is going to
influence how much of it you can eat and
have all these great plant nutrients in
your diet so this has been a novel thing
that wasn't a very fast initially to get
into marketplace luckily I have a great
ally in this process so I am very
fortunate to work with a renowned
farm-to-table chef dan barber one of the
world leaders in this and as we started
to develop this in terms of co-creation
of this new squash it was working with
him in the fields as an opportunity to
taste together see the techniques how we
get the most flavor out of it up here is
the four I was sadly to Instagram a
while ago so I started to eat it before
taking the picture where you see this
beautiful small squash something that's
convenient that fits and some family
sizes nowadays is able to be more of a
side dish rather than kind of filling up
the dishes concentrating the flavor
concentrating the nutrition and also one
of the things that does it we realized
at the time is on the plate it can
resemble what it looks like in the field
and so it's really bringing some of that
field present to you on the plate and so
that's kind of some of the farm-to-table
connection it can make and it has
received a lot of popularity it's been
described in many food magazines media
and I've seen
from seeing I was talking about a
Netflix and a great documentary also
it's achieved one of the things that is
two vegetables get to have apples will
know by variety name you might be going
to the orchards and homecoming in the
fall be getting a Snapdragon Apple so
this is a butternut squash is actually
sold by name not just a butternut squash
but honey nut squash and as we've
continued to go along there's been a lot
we can do to make the food we have
available to us we the farms they can
grow up forth more exciting more
distinctive to be able to really
showcase what we're developing give
consumers give all of us a new flavors
to try we've been in many of the seed
catalogs you'll see this year there's
the white cucumber behind me martini
that has also a fantastic yield for the
grower and a much more delicious refined
flavor than many other cucumbers you'll
have the Havana the pepper which is a
habanero pepper with the spice removed
but it keeps the flavor of a habanero
peppers you can experience all those
flavors without the burn and so it's a
great way to see all the steps of flavor
that's in the produce around us and some
diversity to really help make some of
the produce more competitive with some
of the other food choices we have and we
can continue to to push this and work
for some more ornamental edibles and try
to get peppers that are both loaded with
vitamin C and are just a nice snack size
so it's a more convenient way to go to
be eating delicious you know hopefully
compelling produce and also a plant that
even as an ornamental and it works in
many more areas and we might have
available to grow food for those of us
that might have to have more of a
balcony space than a garden space and so
in this process as I continue to be
really excited about this co-creation of
this avant-garde produce new exciting
increasing the flavor
and the appeal of that and making a more
noticeable and transcends enjoying
seeing farmers it incorporates this into
other growing I had started to really
think this is what farm-to-table was
about to be able to get all these great
new exciting things for the farmers to
grow and if I was fortunate that again
this is where chef Barbara came in to
correct me and they will no not about
that you know so we're supporting the
food system and it's also is really
about trying to figure also
farm-to-table and so what do the farms
have what is the best way to support the
bounty that's there sustainably on the
farm and how do we integrate that into
our diet into what's being served and
showed and celebrated and so I found
myself in some interesting breeding
projects at the end of the season the
beginning of the season before you are
having a harvest from a field or right
before the frost like this is in this
top panel and you've gotten all the the
right produce that there is out of the
field there's still a lot in the field
in many cultures outside the US they
would be looking at how they can avoid
wasting all of this it's something that
we are starting to tackle is how to look
at food waste and so the project they
kind of evolved into is looking at the
CEO to figure out well here's a field of
squash all this foliage that's left it
could just be something that we could
incorporate into our cuisine adapt to
our environment what some other cultures
do so although I've spent much of my
time here selecting for the tastiest
squash I found myself going through the
field finding the tastiest squash stems
and joy looking for something that we
can get this other food that kind of
fits have Dan's vision and so we ended
up with actually a delightful squash
penne pasta so it's gluten free it
exists comes right from the plant the
the squash plant but it
something that is abundant throughout
the field throughout the season and is
something that is nutritious and fitting
right into another use of farm can have
for much of what it's already producing
that otherwise be wasted
some of the challenges some of you might
be close to experiencing some of these
it burns at home the dreaded to come
bird beetles as they come in the squash
especially and as they do fully the
squash there are some different controls
we can use an insecticide that now we
are trying to discuss more about how
they may be or impacting pollinator
health and so looking at ways to avoid
that it turns out there's some natural
diversity within squash we can start to
leverage and use to be able to create
squash the beetles will leave along that
we will still find tasty but the beetles
will find it tasteful and it's as simple
as see a golden zucchini here that the
beetles will perfectly ravage and a
straight neck or crookneck summer squash
that they leave alone so for me as a
plant breeder it is as simple as
crossing the two of them together of
cross-pollination and then going through
the generations to be able to find rice
and emerge the best of all those
characteristics towards a more
sustainable harvest however that's not
the only insect threat out there and
talking to growers in the southeast who
have given up growing zucchini as we're
about to be flooded with zucchini you
can kind of imagine what threat they
must be to not produce Metheny so but
there's other squash squash that are
naturally resistant to some of the other
tests insects we might experience in
your garden and your fields in your farm
so above me here is a Trump and Shino
squash an Italian heirloom squash
selected for flavor that you don't see
much in the marketplace and so as I try
to work a Dan to how can we adapt this
to some some of other ways of cooking
and preparation and also to make it more
delicious and sustainable through a
variety of taste tests we are able to
science on my breeding lines that are
excelling in the kitchen and are
delicious and sustainable on the plate
and so that's really what much of the
farm-to-table on the farm to fork
movement have meant to me it's both
trying to create new varieties to really
excite us in nourish us and when we can
find them and incorporate them into our
diets more and more out of just natural
beyond like we should be eating these
things more but a drive and desire to
eat them more and also ensuring that
we're also really about the farmer the
grower and how we can take things that
are thriving for them and incorporate
that into our vision and plan for this
new cuisine thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu